normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government the
Marvels sets a new record for lowest
grossing MCU MCU movie ever the Marvels
managed to do worse than the Incredible
Hulk a 2008 movie that grossed just 260
million after its run in the movie
theaters so uh wow you know I I know a
lot of people probably don't care but I
just want to point out this is like the
end of an era for Disney Disney is
spiraling into the gutter the Marvels
with their let me show you the
characters look we got um look at this
you know what this looks like this looks
like your your your late
90s like fast food restaurant ad where
you've got and I mean it look you've got
a white woman a black woman and an
ethnically ambiguous woman and I don't
mean it to be a dick but when they they
they would always show these like
cartoon characters in these commercials
like McDonald's or whatever and you're
like that's a white woman that's a black
woman and that woman could could be
Asian middle eastern she could be Arabic
she could be Latino like we don't know
for sure and that was the point they're
trying to show this you know like look
at all of these people of different
backgrounds and they did and and get
this they say after being released about
a month ago the film which notably
features uh Brie Larson managed to gross
only $80 million in North America and
197 million globally the Hulk is widely
considered to be one of the worst films
they've ever done and now they've made a
movie that did even
worse this is good news and I bring you
this story today to uh tell you to keep
your head up because the culture war is
um well we're winning it and Disney
stated to their investors that they
screwed up royally and this is such a
tremendous nuclear bomb of a failure for
a movie that uh you know I think we're I
think we're going to win this one did
you see it
no why would I go see it oh I have no
interest is that sad for Marvel fans
like if you love the Marvel series is it
hard to see it kind of go up in Flames
like this Infinity war was the end yeah
yeah the the OBS by the time they made
Iron Man 3 I was like why what are they
doing man I was a huge Marvel fan in the
90s and in the early early 2000 but
really the mid90s I
like Iron Man 3 it was just like they
were just I just feel like they were
capitalizing on it at that point I mean
obviously they were when Disney bought
Marvel but Iron Man 3 was like what was
like 2013 or something yeah thereabouts
that was when I was fully like it's gone
it was like it's sixth movie or
something like that that's when I
realized that they were just in it for
the money they didn't care about Marvel
and the heroes themselves and the
journeys and the characters they just
wanted to make a bunch of money off
itude Thor four right is uh there's a
fourth Thor already right why did there
need to be four of them ever though and
they're making more and more Spider-Mans
you want like
look comic books I guess they make
movies they did Iron Man Captain America
and Thor and I'm like makes sense then
they did sequels and they made them to
trilogies then they did Doctor Strange
and I'm like all this fine Guardians of
the Galaxy was interesting to me because
I was like really they think that
franchise is going to do really well and
it did and it was awesome and the way
they did the music and everything was
was was absolutely incredible and then
we end up with uh Avengers Infinity war
and that was like wow that was a big
sent off it was it was a masterfully
done movie it was three it was three
movies inter uh uh spiraled around each
other with the villain as the
protagonist it was it was it was
incredible and then Infinity I'm sorry
uh end game was kind of wonky Nostalgia
welcome to the end have a nice day and
after that it's just been a bunch of
garble Disney nonsense yeah they like
The Infinity Gauntlet was I think
Marvel's one of their best I have it
here I have all six issues of it on my
desk I carry it I carry it around with
me it inspired me as a kid but like they
changed that they made it about the
spectacle that they they do just too
much about the spectacle too much about
colors and big explosions and flying
around and less about the storyline
lines and the characters themselves
which is what made Marvel so great was
like the interpersonal relationships
between the characters and the X-Men for
instance that Wolverine was in love with
cyclops's wife and they had like a
special relationship the two of them um
and then the movies come out and it's
just I don't know oh look at this stop
motion and weird effects and crap Bob
Iger who is uh complaining about Elon hi
Bob says the Marvels was shot during Co
there wasn't as much supervision on the
set so to speak where we have Executives
that are really looking over what's
being done day after day after day he
argued that prior records uh uh that
prior records the studio set in the
billions of dollars have put
expectations out of whack we got to the
point where if a film didn't do a
billion dollars in global box office we
are a disappointment that's an
unbelievably high standard and I think
we have to get more realistic yeah um
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 fared well of
the summer grossing $845 million in the
box office and I definitely went to go
see that it was certainly not as good as
Guardians 1 is is is awesome and it's
mostly the the soundtrack and then they
did with two they tried you know aging
some of the music I think I I don't
think the soundtrack was as good in the
third one but I'll I'll go see those
movies the Marvel is garbage it's woke
garbage it's girl power diversity
nonsense that I'm not interested in
watching the first Marvel Captain Marvel
was so bad it's it's just they tried
making a female a a feminist hero's
journey where it's like it's the men
that are holding you down the power was
inside of you the whole time but the men
were holding you back that's that's the
premise of the film
and I'm just like that is the worst
thing I've ever seen yeah and then they
tried to make another one I'm not going
to go see it people are tired of it I
feel like there's just since we've gone
from you know a merit-based system
there's been a decline across all
Industries we're no longer hiring you
know the best writer that can produce
the best script we're hiring someone
because they subscribe to this W Dogma
this belief system or because they check
an affirmative action box and I think
you're going to continue to see just
massive flops like this in every
industry if you do that and especially
art and entertainment yeah see look
Robert Downey Jr is a legend and uh they
made him Iron Man and he nailed it and
Brie Larson was a diversity cast and she
does not have the talent nor the
capabilities nor the right build to play
Captain Marvel in the first place it's a
guy Captain Marvel was a guy 70s it's
supposed to be a man why they cast a
woman as Marvel no no no no okay okay
look look look look you're getting
you're getting into the deep the no but
the real issue is that they there is a
female Captain Marvel they changed it in
the comics the story progressed and they
wanted to make the female version okay
getting a dainty five how old is how
tall is Brie 5'6 and she weighs 100
pound soaking wet I'm like that right
there is bad casting but what they
wanted to do was they were like the time
of men is over they wanted to make a
Marvel lead I think I think Brie Larson
is was the knife in the chest of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because they
want they were like Robert dowy Jr is
he's he's going to be out it's been 10
years years we're going to need someone
to come in and take the lead role in
this franchise and they chose Brie
Larsson who I think has talent but
certainly not for this role they said
just get us a woman they chose Bri it
was the it was the worst casting
decision ever made she's 100 PB soaking
wet and 5 foot6 or whatever maybe she's
5'7 5 5' seven there you go I'll give I
was off by an inch are you kidding me
they're they're like I I said this Robin
Wright would have been way better for
Captain Marvel way better she's an older
more mature and she's she's already
shown that she can play these roles this
was a huge screw up but if you look at
the Marvels itself I mean come on
they're only doubling down on the
diversity narrative it seems weird and
on top of that it's not relatable like
if you want to have a female Captain
Marvel okay I'll grant you that maybe
you want to shake it up the car the
Comics change but the storyline should
also appeal to women and I don't think
feminism actually appeals to women so if
you write a feminist story not only is
maybe this actress who's in another
context but poorly cast here that's
already a challenge to overcome and then
you have this Narrative of like and then
men are your enemies which I don't think
that's how a lot of women feel and so
it's just making nothing relatable women
don't see themselves in the lead actress
they don't they don't see how she's
carrying off this role and they don't
like the storyline well she was uh she
did well in Scott Pilgrim when she
played a snoody like I said she's
talented in some places she could be
well cast other elsewhere but instead
like was she just like trendy at the
time they were like we got to get Brie
Larson never mind what this is actually
supposed to be doing what they thought
with a lot of these uh uh the castings
were like we'll get someone who's up and
coming and make them big because our
movies are so popular we don't got to
pay a premium for them like I thing
about Robert Dany Jr I'm pretty sure it
was with Iron Man they were like they
didn't want to cast him because they
were like your your history and drug
abuse were not interested and then it
was like something happened where it was
really hard but he he they they agreed
to give him the rule and then he nailed
it and then and it relaunched him in a
lot of ways right right and then what
they did with a lot of the casting
decisions for Marvel movies was no names
like small smaller actors who looked
like they were on the upand cominging
and Brie Larson was the failure and they
needed someone to carry the torch for
Robert Downey Jr and they chose the
worst person and the the franchise is
fizzled and just crumbled and they've
destroyed everything from underneath
them so uh get woke go broke they've
admitted get woke go broke we have been
warning them of get woke go broke and it
feels really really good to watch them
get woke and go broke when I look at
these movies and I don't I honestly I
don't go watch them I'll I'll see like
ads and stuff I see Mark Ruffalo and uh
what's his name from Clueless who I love
he's great Paul Rd Paul Rudd and like um
Scarlett Johansson and they all look
like Paul R A little bit not so much but
they all look like they have this fake
like intensity it's like we're super
rich and we're on a Hollywood movie set
right now look at how intense we are I
just that's the vibe I get none of that
is like I'm never afraid for the
characters I'm never worried that
they're not going to just dominate their
surroundings even if they get hit I know
they're superheroes and they're going to
get back up even if they bleed they're
going to be be fine and that's just it
totally lacking the whole you know
Superman losing his powers is one of the
greatest things about Superman that he
has a vulnerability and I don't get was
was I think that came about because the
voice actor for the cartoon or something
was going on vacation for which one what
cartoon I could be wrong about this I
read somewhere that Superman originally
did not have a weakness but the voice
actor wanted to go on vacation so they
were like Superman was made ill by
kryptonite so he's out that's funny yeah
it was something like that was like a
radio show is that what it was real life
you know everybody's got a weakness I
don't know if it was a radio show or TV
show or something I don't know I just
read something on the Internet that
means it's true so is how the internet
it wasn't News Guard certified so I
could be completely wrong about a bot
wrote it ESPN posted it oh man we are we
are so close to uh AI reality man people
are just going to be like plug me in I'm
done El what was it Elon Mustang
artificial general intelligence is three
years away that's the point at which you
can just put on a VR headset and say I
want to play video game game where I
fight dragons and then the world just
forms all around you and you're fighting
dragons we got to get the movement done
we've got the treadmill downstairs but
it's still a little tight have you tried
it no that was the feedback that I've
heard so far is it's a little hard to to
get cuz you're in a harness and you're
like not really walking yeah and you
can't get those long gates for long
running yet yeah but it's not look
you're just going to hook your brain up
to it and you're going to go full on
you're running your bra yeah you're
going to go full on brain in a vet
that's the future of AI once we get
artificial general intelligence the AI
will just literally create the
schematics for human computer brain
interfaces it will literally just be
like boom here you go it's going to be
weird because you're going to have a
section of people who just flee to the
woods there are people who like are
interested in technology and will want
to engage with it and then there will be
other people who are like I am out we're
going off the grid pack up the water
let's get out of here no I don't think
they I mean have a whole Mountain
community that the AI can't find they're
not going to flee to the woods the AI is
not going to kill you it's going to give
you everything you've ever wanted
there's going to be people who just
don't and there's like I think people in
cities are going to be completely
removed from the question you're G to I
yo one by one your neighbors will stop
answering their phones your friends will
stop answering their phones slowly over
time you'll you'll have drinks on Friday
night after work and then someone
doesn't show up and you hit them up
you're like n I'm going to stay in
tonight one by one your friends stop
showing up to the bar until it's just
you sitting there and being like yo
where is everybody and they're all
plugged into their own micro universes
where they to be God they're all having
drinks at the bar in the metaverse
you'll be the last one to realize no
they're not playing with they're not
going to be playing games with each
other dude they're like you're some dude
you know is going to be like sorry I'm
you know I'm busy and he's going to be
in Skyrim fighting dragons another guy
is going to be in like a Special Forces
Unit you know it's Call of Duty ask then
the women are going to be playing 50
Shades of Gray in fact probably they're
all just in porn they're all just doing
some weird crazy combination of
everything where they're fighting
dragons and porn at the same time thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net